the phone is constantly protecting you
for example if you're not at home at in
the office all the radio signals are
gonna turn are gonna be turned off
automatically so you cannot be traced
unless you go to a Starbucks and you
connect to the Wi-Fi then then turns it
on that's that's an important problem
because they can track you just because
if you have because of having your Wi-Fi
on we make sure that your apps that you
have installed your your Facebook your
Twitter or any other app that you use
don't leak data out of out of your phone
unless you know that's happening and
many other features together with the
solid suite of phone and texting app
that we have that help protect you from
a 360-degree approach what makes it safe
is it special encryption what it's well
what we do especially for the
communication parts when you make a
phone call when you send the text is
that there's no infrastructure in the
middle it's almost no infrastructure in
the middle when you make a phone call my
phone and your phone exchange the keys
between them there's no server in the
middle holding them so no government or
no attacker can go to that middle point
to intercept the communication it's what
we call said RTP a fumarole keys change
and it's a revolutionary technology
because also for an enterprise they
don't need to buy expensive equipment to
install in their server rooms they can
just buy the phones or buy the licenses
and put in their iPhone and the Android
phones and and it works out of the box
so I assume then my older iPhone 6 is a
lot less secure right how vulnerable are
we out there in the public to potential
hacks
well we have studied says that 97% of
the apps that people not just have to
stole leaked data one way or another
yeah leakage in purpose because the apps
make money out of that flashlight
application so flossing you know that
you click and they flash turns on yeah I
know that all the time well the top 5 in
the marketplace make money by taking
your contact list and spamming them
selling them to spam lists that's how
they they are free right so what we say
is that if a product is free you're
likely to be the product so you are the
products are usually making money out of
you you don't know when do you think
you'll sell it here in China
I think it might do okay here China
right now is in a market in which we're
launching our products directly it's not
it's not it's not as you need a license
to sell it here right correct there's a
rich set of regulations also some
specifics out of the market that we're
another bird asia-pacific is one of our
core regions so we sell early to South
Korea which started selling Japan Hong
Kong itself is a big business hard for
us so we're growing a lot in the region
just China is not the moment yet we I'm
sure that will be there in the future do
you think you can get a license given
that your software yeah we're going to
probably get around some of the spying
itself it's a pro needs to be addressed
and stir-frying that affects any
corporation wherever they are but we
just cannot commit to a timeline